[Music]
so what do the early 2000s san antonio
spurs and the current day phoenix suns
and the galaxy s 22 series all have in
common
well they're all drama-free they're all
kind of a bit boring and all quietly
really really good
so those spurs weren't really just a
one-trick pony of being more athletic or
dunking all over the top of people or
just shooting tons of three-pointers or
really any of the things that a casual
fan would immediately appreciate just
good solid fundamentals ball movement
high percentage shots and sharing the
load same kind of thing with the phoenix
suns of today they don't necessarily
have one huge standout mvp superstar but
like the whole team is really really
good and there aren't really any
weaknesses and they're quietly the
number one team in basketball this phone
is boring like i'm not the only one
who's thought that and said that but
that's what happens when a phone gets so
really good across the board that there
aren't really any weaknesses because
they didn't really take any huge risks
they just took a good thing and made it
better so i appreciate that you know
what you're getting with a samsung
flagship very similar design to last
year just a little bit smaller and a
little more squared off and with glass
on the back now instead of plastic that
little spot where your finger rests
under the camera bump too if you use it
without a case it's a little more sharp
but i got used to that pretty quickly
but we all expect an ip68 water
resistant phone solid speakers clicky
buttons the best ultrasonic fingerprint
reader in the game a nice satin finish
you know not all of these things can be
said about every other phone but they're
all here and i even want to give a shout
out to the in the hand feel of the
smaller galaxy s22 so i talk about in
the hand feel all the time but samsung
made both of these phones smaller than
last year the s22 plus went from 6.7
inches to 6.6 diagonally still big but
then the smaller s22 went from 6.2 to
6.1 inches
and
dare i say it has a bit of a compact
feel to it now obviously it sounds crazy
to say that about a phone that still has
a six inch screen but the fact that i'm
coming from bigger phones combined with
the flat sides and the tiny symmetrical
bezels and the corner to corner display
this has me feeling like it's about as
compact as the phone can possibly be and
i'm almost tempted to have it in the
running for maybe compact phone of the
year maybe it just holds that lead for
right now in february but speaking of
displays that's the one thing that we
definitely know samsung two have been
good at for a long time this year though
there was a bit of confusion around them
so let's clear that up so both the s22
and s22 plus have flat 1080p 120 hertz
adaptive ammo led panels the plus is
obviously bigger and it also has the
higher max brightness of
1750 nits where the s22 gets up to a
very respectable 1300 nits they're both
very viewable outdoors although the peak
brightness on the bigger phones and also
the ultra is crazy bright like you can
view it in direct sunlight it's awesome
but there was a question about whether
these were ltpo displays or not so
that's that newer tech that allows you
to modulate the display refresh rate
down to 10 hertz to save battery so i'd
ask samsung and i mentioned this in the
impressions video that they told me that
these are not ltpo displays
but then at the same time on the spec
sheet it also said that these go from 10
to 120 hertz so that was a bit confusing
but now a few days later if you check
samsung's actually changed those spec
sheets and their website saying it can
go from 48 to 120 hertz so they
clarified that data transfer rates to
the display can go as low as 10 hertz
but the display is still refreshing
faster so they updated their site to
reflect the widely recognized industry
standard of the actual refresh rate huh
it's almost like some other companies
sometimes lie to people by expressing
things in other non-standard ways
anyway so it's not the full variable
refresh rate range of ltpo2 like we have
on the ultra which is a bit of a
downside to an 800 to a thousand dollar
phone but aside from that it's a great
bright responsive display in this
adaptive mode and that's what matters
most to me i did notice there's still
some situations and still a few apps
where it kicks down to 60 hertz on
purpose like maps apps like waze and
google maps and still the galaxy store
app for some reason but with all the
color customization and a really good
auto brightness the only possible
downside with this screen would be
battery life and on top of that the only
concern for me really going into
reviewing these phones was the battery
life because number one both the phones
are smaller and so both of them have a
300 milliamp hour smaller battery than
last year
and number two the new snapdragon 8 gen
1 chip had some concerns about it it's
that's obviously brand new and supposed
to be very efficient but it also appears
to be geared to be a very high-end chip
very high performance so it performs
really well puts up great numbers better
than previous chips on benchmarks and it
crushes gaming but it runs a little hot
and if there's a reason almost every
flagship you see coming out with this
new chip also has like a huge section in
their presentation about their new
massive super innovative new cooling
solution so with no ltpo
smaller batteries and a potentially
higher power drawing chip i was a little
concerned about battery life on these
phones
turned out to be
fine
not amazing not like headline making but
san antonio spurs boring level
good so david was testing the s22 plus
most at the studio and got a solid day
and a half of use so starting a day at 7
00 am and then getting to 1 pm the next
day before the battery dies pretty solid
and i was using a smaller s22 for a few
days and had no problem ending a normal
day with 10 to 20 percent left now if i
did a lot of high brightness navigation
and gaming big power draw stuff i could
take big chunks out of this battery fast
so that did not surprise me with this
chip it is a more efficient four
nanometer process node now so it does
really well with standby but you can
absolutely burn through it with heavy
use something to keep in mind too though
the s22 plus has a better overall
battery experience because it also
supports 45 watt fast charging instead
of the 25 watts on the smaller phone now
it doesn't come with it so it's 50 bucks
extra to get that 45 watt charger but
that's a difference to note you wanna
know something i did find i like less
about the s22 though than last year it's
a subtle one but it's real the vibration
motor
so the haptics are still actually really
good and really strong and clicky and
responsive and i love that about it but
they've switched from a z-axis vibration
motor to an x-axis vibration motor
it doesn't sound like it make a huge
difference but that's a difference in
the direction of the pulsing of the
motor
and that makes it a lot less strong in
my pocket and on a table for feeling the
vibrations i missed a lot of
notifications just because it didn't
strongly buzz me enough
[Music]
so yeah i don't know that was a subtle
thing you can still feel the vibrations
really well and turn vibration intensity
all the way up but the direction is
different not sure why maybe space
savings but it's real maybe the most
exciting potential superstar upgrade on
these phones though is
the cameras the s22 having a major
camera upgrade would be like the 2016
golden state warriors signing kevin
durant making them the clear number one
favorite right you have a new 50
megapixel main camera a 10 megapixel 110
degree ultra wide and another 10
megapixel 3x telephoto camera but this
new camera system is more
harrison barnes than kevin durant
meaning it's it's really good but it's
not gonna blow your mind at how good it
is i love that we take photos this good
from a smartphone for granted you give
it pretty much any normal lighting
situation and handles it really well
samsung's colors are nicely balanced
they've hit their stride with processing
that isn't too overly sharp or saturated
the ultrawide is definitely softer than
the main camera but it still does well
with a lot of light and the telephoto is
rock solid no weird hdr haloing issues
and pictures no white balance
inconsistency problems no auto focus
issues and pretty minimal shutter lag
it's just
boring tim duncan with the bank shot
level solid also i i gotta say i love
that it no longer punches into 3x when i
shoot 8k video on the phone i know ak
video is not the most popular feature
but last time the higher resolution
camera was the telephoto so if i shot 8k
video it would punch into a 3x crop
that was rough it doesn't do that
anymore now it's just a tiny crop in on
that main sensor which is actually a
smaller crop than on the ultra because
the ultra is cropping into the middle 33
megapixels of this massive 108 megapixel
sensor so i'd actually rather shoot 8k
video on the regular s22s than the s22
ultra now i'm not going to do it because
it's still 24 fps which
is the wrong frame rate
shopped.onbc.com but still like why
couldn't samsung add a little switch to
make it 8k 30 if i wanted to the last
three snapdragon chips have been able to
support 8k 30fps video and i know you
know 8k is supposed to be a super high
end cinematic feature but at least
buried in the settings let me do ak-30
if i want to
i don't know maybe it's a samsung thing
other phones have been able to do it
not samsung now there are way more
software improvements with these cameras
like night photography which samsung
calls knightography because they have to
name everything for some reason but
that's for better detail and night shots
and ai stereo portrait mode improvements
for better cutouts and space zoom
stability locking and auto framing that
can track up to 10 faces around a frame
and a new separate expert raw app i'm
going to talk way more about all this
camera stuff in the s22 ultra review
video which is coming soon definitely
make sure you subscribe to see that one
when it comes out but in this one i
wanted to talk about its default status
which you know especially in the u.s
now it's kind of a running joke that
outside of the tech community we've
heard people call it like iphones and
galaxies like they've just been so
dominant here anyway that it's kind of
already understood but especially with
the s22 series now more than ever it's
sort of solidified itself as the default
android phone uh which is crazy when you
consider what the pixel 6 was supposed
to be now i used to rag on samsung's
software for being incredibly clunky
weighted down with bloatware looking
like a cartoon skin on top of android
while the pure google experience from a
nexus or a pixel or even a lightweight
skin from motorola or oneplus was the
way to go but today now that oxygen os
has gone downhill and the pixels are a
buggy mess samsung's one ui has evolved
into easily one of the most stable
performant feature-packed android
experiences out there they loop in the
google stuff when it's good like having
a google page next to your home screen
and the new material you wallpaper
picker from android 12 which lets you
pick colors from your wallpaper to be
accent colors and the menus of your
phone but then they also sprinkle in
tons of their own samsung features that
you can decide to use if you want but
not only that samsung has also vaulted
ahead and is doing some things better
than google's own phones so one thing
that i've noticed is there's a new
google messages app as the default on
all these samsung phones which is cool
if you go to the play store and try to
download google messages it says you
already have it installed but when you
open it it's a samsung skinned version
they're the only ones who have been able
to do that so now it has that half
screen reachable ui to match the rest of
samsung's one ui then there's a new
google duo feature that launched where
you can essentially watch a youtube
video together with someone while on a
video call like apple did with share
play over facetime and this feature has
launched in google duo
on the galaxy s 22s only first
why so you have to use a galaxy s22 or
s22 ultra to use this feature which i
did we tried it and it worked but there
is no timeline for when this feature
will show up on other android phones
including google's own pixel
even though google made this feature and
then on top of that samsung is promising
four years of software updates for the
galaxy s22s after they launch
that's more than the three years of
software updates that google is
promising with their own phone in the
pixel you see what i'm getting at so the
galaxy s 22s are boring yes but the
boringness comes from them having
basically no glaring flaws and makes
them incredibly easy to recommend i wish
they were more sustainable i wish they
included a charger in the box so you
didn't have to go out of your way to buy
a 45 watt charger and make more waste to
actually use that feature and i can
appreciate that some plastics being used
in the phone are made from recycled
fishing nets but that's really only a
tiny dent in the big picture of
samsung's footprint but in that classic
frequently asked question of like if
you're in the market for a flagship
phone right now and i don't know
anything about you
the first phones that i'm gonna bring up
are the iphone 13 and the galaxy s 22
plus
and they've earned that spot
that's been it thanks for watching catch
you guys the next one
peace